the elected leaders
as well as uh at the time
uh we also had governor newsom pushing
hard as well
look we have two excellent senators
dianne feinstein and alex padilla i tell
you what alex you don't look any worse
for the wear man you're looking awful
good
you're looking awful good
and nanette uh i uh i think you always
look good particularly compared to these
guys you know i mean
and me but seriously thank you that for
the fire you bring you bring some fire
to this i really mean it it's in your
heart
and alan lowenthal has been working on
this for a long time alan and i just had
a
little meeting together
we got to change that one we've got we
can't we can't give up we gotta turn
this corner
and uh and john uh i i can't thank you
you're uh you're the real deal
anybody uh i won't get into getting you
in trouble but thanks for sticking up
for me um
and look and we have a labor secretary
that i'm his translator he's marty
wallace from boston
and uh
but if you need any if you understand
all the things you got to know he always
has your back he always has your back
i had an uncle you say joey
you're labor from belt buckle to shoe
soul well he's labored from forehead to
the tip of his toes used to run the
laborers out union look folks um
today i'd like to speak about my top
economic priority
fighting inflation
i understand americans are anxious and
the anxious is a good reason
i was raised in a household when the
price of gasoline rose precipitously it
was the discussion at the table it made
a difference when food prices went up
but we've never seen anything like
putin's tax on both food and gas
america should also understand our
economy has unique strengths
that we can build on the job market is
the strongest it's been since world war
ii notwithstanding the inflation
we added another 390 000 jobs last month
8 million 700 000 new jobs since i took
office an all-time record never that
many jobs in that period of time
unemployment rate
is near historic lows
millions of americans are moving up to
better jobs and better pay
and since i took office families are
carrying less debt on average in america
they have more savings than they've had
and we're doing it all while cutting the
federal deficit by
1.7 trillion dollars this year
and 320 billion last
if i hear one of my maga friends once
again talk about debt and deficits i'm
go
i'm gonna be good
they increased the deficit by 2 trillion
bucks anyway that's another story but
look this is the largest decline in
american history
because of the progress american can
tackle inflation from a position of
strength unlike any other country in the
world because every country in the world
is getting a big bite and piece of this
inflation worse than we are in the vast
majority countries around the world but
make no mistake about it
i understand
inflation is a real challenge to
american families
today's inflation report
confirmed what americans already know
putin's price hike is hitting america
hard
gas prices at the pump
energy and food prices account for half
of the monthly price increases since may
inflation outside of energy and food
what the economists call core inflation
moderated the last two months not enough
but in moderators come down
we needed to come down much more quickly
my administration could continue
everything we can to lower the prices to
the american people and the congress has
to act and they have mentally
one of the key ways to fight inflation
is by lowering the cost of moving goods
through the supply chain when i first
started talking about the supply chain
when i came here well over a year ago
the american people understandably
wondered supply chain well i mean that's
not a usual part of their jargon every
day but they understand it fully now
they understand it if you can't get the
material needed to build a product
you're building whether it's an
automobile or whatever it is it makes it
difficult to be able to move that's
called the supply chain
that's why i've been focused on ports
last fall
ports around the world were congested
through the disruptions caused by the
pandemic
so we brought together port operators
shipping companies and labor
and to ease the bottlenecks and as a
result
over the holidays last 97 of all the
packages were delivered on time and on
shelves when they went christmas
shopping remember we weren't going to
have anything on those shows you all did
it no no not a joke you did it
on time with minimal delays delivery
times are actually quicker than they
were before the pandemic
and today there are about 40 percent
fewer containers clogging the docks on
long for long periods of time than there
were last november
this may was the strongest month in the
port of los angeles history the
strongest month in its history and we're
helping fund improvements
[Applause]
because of what my friends in the
congress have done we passed the we
passed the infrastructure bill and we're
and we're funding major new initiatives
on the docks
on dock rail systems port of long beach
has moved goods more quickly a port
electrification so communications near
the ports can be and communities can
breathe cleaner air because they're
using electric machines that are not
generated using gas coal etc
and we're continuing to expand capacity
of our ports thanks to the bipartisan
infrastructure law look
this is a time
we took a different approach also to
trucking remember last december
we brought together industry and labor
to tackle problems facing truck drivers
it took the double we had to double the
number of commercial driver licenses
being issued by the states in order to
speed things up we did it
we sped the creation of registration of
apprenticeships allowing aspiring
drivers to earn while they were learning
the result we had a record-setting
employment on trucking earlier this year
and trucker's wages went up even after
accounting for inflation
we're going to keep at it with the new
super chain envoy general steve lyons
general lyons is a four-star general he
handled the transportation of a little
bit of thing he had transportation
command only tens of millions of
billions of tons of things to move from
little things like tanks and aircraft
and all that but all kidding aside he's
come off the sidelines he's retired he's
helped us identify and get ahead of the
challenges that raise
that that arise at our ports our
railroads and on the road this is about
reducing costs for families
you know
i have to admit to you
a lot of us have elected officials been
in office for a while
every once in a while something you
learn makes you viscerally angry
like if you had the person in front of
you you'd want to pop them
i really mean it
there are nine
nine major ocean line shipping companies
that ship from asia to the united states
nine
they form three consortium
these companies have raised their prices
by as much as one
thousand percent so everything coming
from asia they they get 90 some percent
of it the stuff coming from asia
they've raised it by 1 000
that's why i called on congress to crack
down on their foreign owned
foreign owned shipping companies that
raised their prices
while raking in just last year
190 billion dollars in profit
a seven-fold increase in one year
seven-fold increase 190 billion
the senate passed legislation i'm
hopeful the house is going to act soon
to crack down on these companies as i've
asked
and lower the cost
i'm grateful 102 californians speaker
pelosi and john germany i for uh for
leading this effort thanks john i really
mean it it's a big deal people at home
trying to make it you know
paycheck to paycheck or wondering like
what in god's name to nine
understandably nine shipping companies
have to do it
well almost everything you're doing
everything from what you're eating to
what you're having to drive to what
you're
with what you need in your home
it relates to supply chains and what's
coming from abroad i'm doing everything
in my power to blunt putin's price
height and bring down the cost of gas
and food
i led the world to coordinate the
largest release of the global oil
reserves in history
240 million barrels to boost supply to
keep price from rising even more
thanks to america's leadership in
diplomacy we've helped europe reduce its
reliance on russian oil by tripling our
natural gas systems to europe compared
to last year
i'm working closely with our european
partners to get 20 million tons of grain
locked in ukraine already in their silos
now
ukraine and russia the two major
suppliers of grain and corn
they have 20 million barrels i mean 20
million
in in their in in their silos right now
so we're trying to help
them to get that and the russians are
blocking the export they're not allowed
out to the black sea and we're trying to
figure out how to get it out of the
country to get here to around the world
it will bring down prices but there's
more
there's more than one way to solve this
problem
we're continuing working to bring down
food prices and gas prices and save
families mother money by dealing with
other items my dad used to say
it's all about the standard of living
how much you have left in the paycheck
at the end of the month
how much is left to do the basic things
so if you add up all the things that
people need
just to do their to do everything from
take care of their kids to turn the heat
on or the air conditioning on and
everything in between
there's a lot of ways we can reduce
their cost their cost of living
other than if we while we're trying to
get it at the grain
and uh and gas
we laid out a plan for example
lower prescription drug costs
that would fundamentally affect the
well-being of every family those of you
who know somebody who has type 2
diabetes and has it has an insulin
requirement monthly
you know it costs an average of 647
dollars a month
can cost as high as a thousand of some
places you know how much it costs to
make that one little vial of insulin
ten dollars ten ten dollars
no new research has been done since that
is was invented
and the charging is outrageous so i
think we should be able to have
the medicare do what they do when they
deal with the va
va says we're only going to pay you so
much for this
if you don't want to and because they
the medicare negotiates the price for
them
well medicare is able to negotiate the
price on insulin guess what
it comes down a whole hell of a lot
outrageous numbers
so we can put a cap on that's not at 35
a month and they'll still make a
significant profit
10 bucks to manufacture 35 bucks
for example we could begin by lowering
the cost of high-speed internet because
what you all did dealing with the uh uh
with the the the infrastructure bill
working with the server providers we cut
the price and rise raised the speed
potentially lowering high-speed internet
bills on average for average family 30
a month
okay well you're made you're paying an
extra more than 30 a month for your gas
but that still
increases the money out of pocket the
decreased amount you have to put out the
point is
we're doing everything in our power to
lower cost of families but congressional
republicans led by senator rick scott
have a different approach and if you
didn't write it down you'd think i was
making it up
and i mean sincerely
rick scott tried to change his words
yesterday by the way after he introduced
this let's even campaign he's the guy
that had the rica the re-election of the
senators on the republican side
he realized that raising taxes on
working families a little unpopular he
said everybody
no matter what their station if they
don't if they're on welfare should have
pay tax everybody should pay a tax
well but here's the truth
one concrete plan that i laid out was
going to raise taxes on working families
an average of one thousand five hundred
dollars a month
while we have
54 corporations out there didn't pay any
tax the last two years and made 40
billion dollars
they don't want to tax them at all
they don't want tax billionaires are
literally paying a lower tax rate than
longshoremen are paying
literally on a percentage basis
so he hasn't walked back from his plans
on health care he says we have to do now
that we finally got
the affordable care act functioning and
the price is down an average of 400
bucks for people he wants to eliminate
it again we're back at one eliminate it
again
so and by the way the one that's the
best thing that the republicans are
pushing now in reelection
is that they think that medicare
i'm not making this up
go online look medicare
social security and medicaid medicaid
go on the chopping block every five
years what that means is at the end of
five years they go out of existence
unless they're affirmatively voted back
into existence every five years
medicare
social security medicaid
and they forget
people paid for their social security
they paid for it
and you know what's going to happen
people say well they'll never eliminate
it all but they'll what they'll do
they'll be able to pick it apart they'll
be able to cut it back that's the whole
objective
and folks you know it's not right
it's simply not right
and i disagree and that's what look this
is not your father's republican party
this is a different deal it really is
i've worked with a lot of honorable
republicans very conservative
republicans over the year when i was a
senator
but this is the maga gang this is the
maga crowd i really mean it they have a
fundamentally different view
of the role of government
and who should pay what
and i'm going to work with anyone
democrat republican independent deliver
real solutions for families look
because of the strong foundation we've
built
we're better positioned just about any
country in the world to overcome the
global of the global inflation we're
seeing
and to take the next step towards
performing a historic recovery
a new moment and i count recovery as
going from where we are today in terms
of the economy to stability to make it
stable
it is strong as can be but for inflation
but for gas and food
and look we have to keep going we have
to keep coming together to find common
ground to solve problems like we've done
in the ports and in trucking
we continue to build the extraordinary
progress we've made so we've got to
continue building this economy from the
bottom up and the middle out
and i mean that literally i am so sick
and tired of trickle down economics it
does not work
when the middle class is doing well and
they do well because of labor when the
middle class is doing well
the poor have a way up and the wealthy
do very very well
they have never been hurt when the
middle class is doing well never
never
so it's about time we start to regather
and remember who we are and get a lot of
this done
but there's no better place to start it
than right here in the port letting
those nine
foreign shippers understand
the rip-off is over
thank you
[Applause]
we're going to make sure that everybody
knows exxon's prophecy why don't you
tell them what exxon's profits were this
year this quarter
exxon made more money than god this year
and by the way nothing's changed and
they're not by the way one thing i want
to say about the oil companies
you talk about how we have they have 9
000 permits to drill
they're not drilling
why aren't they drilling
because they make more money not
producing more oil the price goes up
number one
and number two the reason they're not
drilling is they're buying back their
own stock
which should be taxed quite frankly
buying back their own stock and making
no new investments
so uh i i always thought republicans are
for investment
exxon start investing start paying your
taxes thanks
[Applause]
all right
[Music]
i couldn't even get a shot
your head's nice